2018 graduates are you excited to be
here during your time here you have each
made an indelible mark on this community
[Applause]
[Music]
we committed to learning these lessons
from and with each other fellow students
have taught me that it is important not
to be a voice for others rather we
should use the voice that we have to
bring others into the conversation I
learned that while we are capable of
doing great things the most important
thing that any of us can be is a great
friend you guys all you guys here
Carnegie Mellon students Carnegie Mellon
graduates my people in life in life get
all the experience you can while you're
young go for the experience versus a
paycheck do what's right really do
what's right and it won't hurt you just
keep your priorities straight you'll
have great opportunities ahead
don't let anyone anyone tell you
different do what you think is good for
you that you can contribute that you can
find yourself that you can end that you
love there's sort of a time in your life
when the lifespan of the field where you
know exciting things are happening and
you know these kids they are going to be
the ones who are going to shape the
future but you got to think sort of big
what are the big questions and how can
make the field go forward you need to
start giving back now behave as if you
were successful now because there is a
great need for you than your talents and
your creativity and your thing that you
love is a great need for you to be out
there spreading that in the world with a
great deal of love I learned that at
Carnegie Mellon University a Carnegie
Mellon degree is a sign that you've
surpassed the high standard of
accomplishment in science art and ideas
and that you are ready to use this
knowledge in your lives and future
professions you're ready to take on the
charge of continuing the long-standing
tradition of doing the work that matters
class of 2018 you all possess the
training and intellect to be impactful
actors of the future I am truly excited
for you and I'm excited for the future
which you hold in your hands thank you
for allowing me to share this moment
with you and on behalf of the entire CMU
community congratulations class of 2018
[Music]
you